sempre que eu e minha voz sempre que
entrou e zagallo no brasil essa pergunta
aqui que você lembra das minhas aulas é
uma boa pergunta é uma disciplina que
são dez noites vezes quatro horas mas
aluna minha eu perguntei o que você
lembra as minhas aulas ou ruim
eu me lembro que antes atual lá você
sempre tocava um devedor que de abelha
ele disse olha eu pago o jantar de vocês
três você lembrar de alguma outra coisa
ela falou às vezes é um dvd do windows
professor
de fato a música em si poder de nos
emocionar
eu fico curioso de perguntar pra vocês
que se vão lembrar dessa palestra e
vocês vão dizer você estava com uma
gripe e nada professor que vem eu quero
explorar com vocês um contraponto com
vocês o poder por acaso é uma uma frase
do bob dylan que ele diz assim não há
sucesso como o fracasso não o fracasso
do ponto de vista derrotismo que tudo
acabou e não temos mais nada a fazer
mas o fracasso o recomeço pra casa com
uma forma de você acertar de novo plano
de vôo uma forma de você se reinventar
uma forma de você olhar para si
meus erros e eu gostaria de explorar com
vocês uma história que foi muito
importante na minha vida e na vida da
maioria de vocês que foi a conquista da
lua que aconteceu há 50 anos atrás eu me
lembro como eu fiquei empolgado de certa
maneira a que direcionou a minha
carreira de engenheiro
sabia tudo sobre as missões apollo nos
mínimos detalhes
e e quando a gente olha pra ver
apollo 11 essa revista aqui ó
essa revista original minha na época a
revista de 50 anos
eu me lembro da apollo 11
vocês não lembram como eu me lembro bem
porque eu fazia um churrasco nos estados
unidos
na história de um scan se em janeiro de
6 7 aconteceu uma tragédia amorosa
os três tripulantes da apollo 11
morreram queimados no chão né não foi
uma catástrofe e o programa é é da lua
ficou parado durante alguns anos teve
apolo 23 somente apollo 7 voltou a ter
tripulantes a preocupa 8 foi maravilhosa
foi a primeira vez que o ser humano sai
da órbita da terra e vai até a lua paulo
oito escolas passaram atrás da lua e
durante meia hora não houve comunicação
com eles
ficou aquela na coxa será que eles vão
voltar voltar e os caras saem de trás da
lua e nem pela primeira vez eles tinham
a foto da terra
a foto mais visto até hoje ela terra
maravilhosa ali nasce movimento
ambiental apollo 13 isso que fez após 19
paulo lopes os caras testam o módulo
lunar em volta da terra o que faz apollo
10 voltam pra lua fazem a órbita da lua
com o módulo lunar e apollo 11
os caras chegam à lua me lembro até hoje
inclusive eu gravei na época tinha um
gravadorzinho de rolo eu gravei a
chegada dos carros na rua então quando a
gente olha amigos a gente vê é tantas
dificuldades nas nossas vidas também né
desde o fracasso as lições que a gente
tira do caso
eu aprendi muito com os japoneses bem
japoneses têm o ampara chamado cais em
casa significa o seguinte não há nada
que não possa ser melhorado a nossa tá
bom assim então vamos fazer de uma
maneira mais sustentável uma maneira
mais divertida uma maneira mais rica
kaizen não é kaiser que cai sem eu tinha
idéias pré-concebidas a respeito do
japão
eu achei que lá no japão eu poderia me
comunicar e nem supermercado posto de
gasolina farmácia em inglês eu poderia
conversar com o japonês
fiquei surpreso em perceber que pouco
japonês fala inglês e japonês que fala
inglês não fala inglês
elas falam inglês com sotaque japonês
como é que se fala rossini inglês ray se
você chega num restaurante japonês
você perde mais a japonesinha faz assim
ai ai ai
significa sim mas ela não entendeu não
vai se fala é mais só se fala carne
negras midi e chegada no japão fala mit
japonesinha faz mas não entendi não é
mitch amy tó como é que se fala a
cerveja e nem quis beber no japão webber
é biró 22 você fala
biro biro biro biro brincadeira então a
sua primeira refeição no japão garantida
mito biro biro biro né
e os japoneses têm essa idéia da
melhoria contínua neco é só o japonês
uma vez perguntaram para o comendador
enzo ferrari governador qual é o melhor
carro do mundo é a resposta que ele deu
foi totalmente inusitada e hoje lá na
fábio koff ainda não está escrito
na comendador para o melhor carro do
mundo a próxima ferrari a próxima
ferrari vai ser melhor né
essa idéia do crescimento e da melhoria
contínua
outra coisa que eu aprendi com os
japoneses foi o que eles chamam de
manual de erros do passado
olha que legal eu estava visitando uma
empresa e o palestrante mostra para nós
no livrinho dora é bom errar o erro
permite que a gente vá melhorando sempre
inclusive os japoneses ortodoxos da
qualidade eles assim não me dêem boas
notícias não serve para nada eu quero
mas notícias porque nem eu vou melhorar
eu assisti à palestra e o nosso se ou da
empresa no japão diz assim nós temos
esse livrinho aqui que entra para
trabalhar ganha um livrinho ea primeira
tarefa é o livrinho assim pode errar mas
esses não estando já fizemos faz a erros
novos né altolapa pessoal
não estou dizendo que é a mesma coisa
que violação
são coisas completamente diferentes
então por exemplo em segurança do
trabalho
trabalhei muitos anos em questões de
segurança de trabalho mesmo na aviação é
existe normas rigorosas em cima os
protocolos de sempre tem que ser seguido
é perseverança eu selecionei dos
conselhos ea outra é uma visão positiva
do futuro e esperança
não sei se você sabe a origem wd-40 wd é
o ato de ter vendido ou seja um
bloqueador de água porque número 40
porque o cara tentou 39 estava dando
aula o aluno levantou a mão
o levantamento conclui será que é por
isso que o filho se chama 647 eu acho
que não mas enfim
e nós estamos lá no nosso instituto
ilumina santana
o que nós adoramos os passos e logo que
a gente chegou lá o filho mais velho ou
luís guilherme arquiteto hoje mora na
austrália é segredo precisamos trazer
passarinhos aqui eu queria trazer
periquitos
eu queria mostrar pra vocês um pequeno
vídeo que a gente fez um minuto e meio
lá no instituto que fez do que se não
tivesse hoje uma uma sinfonia todos os
dias de manhã
a gente ficou esperando uma semana duas
colocava comida buscar se repete show
ele chegou a namorada e falou pra ela
não pra ninguém
ae
hoje quando se fala de manhã tem 306
verdinho sair e quando começou o
primeiro visitante
outro ponto absolutamente indispensável
nas realizações
é a atitude mental positiva de uma fase
legal do henry ford
eles assim se você acha que vai dar
certo ou se você acha que não vai dar
certo você acertou
nessa visão positiva do futuro e eu me
lembro quando eu fui escolhido para ser
paraninfo na faculdade de engenharia e
eu apesar de ter muita experiência de
sala de aula
eu nunca tinha falado para 2500 pessoas
no teatro guaíra
apavorado o mesmo e por sorte ou por
azar sobre seis meses antes
sofri seis meses o que você vai dizer
para um grupo de de formatos e eu fiz
uma reflexão bem grande e fui falar com
algumas pessoas que tinham muita canja
de grandes platéias fazer o que eu fazia
falei com um amigo meu é como é que faz
aí como é que a gente enfrenta guaíra
ele falou assim rui vitória no bolso e
apalpou dólares e você sente um cara
poderoso
veja que ideia maluca
na verdade uma outra pessoa assim paul
falou pra mim cocaína de você tá louco
eu fui falar com o professor toninho
o piloto foi o meu para nível que ele
disse o professor
ele era para livro do ano já nem
preparava o discurso nada
a promotoria está apavorado como é que
eu faço calma foi calma calma baixa a
bola você não é o centro das atenções
o centro das atenções são os formandos
os pais todos estão lá olhando os
formandos e vibrando não faça uma grande
bobagem e nem quer vai vai
eu falo assim faça um teste foi depois
do seu discurso
todo mundo tiver lá fora né pergunta às
pessoas sobre o que foi o meu discurso e
muitas pessoas não não percebe então
naquela oportunidade
amigos eu escrevi um conto esse encontro
chama se a viagem 2002 e é uma metáfora
de um jovem que sai para uma longa
viagem e antes de sair pra para a viagem
ele fala com os sete sábios e cada sábio
da pele um presente
foi um final do ponto um minuto porque
que é quando ele encontra o sétimo sábio
antes de sair na próxima jornada o
sétimo sabe eu era o mais antigo e
portanto muito evoluído
diz a lenda que teria vindo de uma
estrela distante para ajudar na evolução
das pessoas através do alto é
desenvolvimento em sua consciência
chamava se anima era uma mulher de rara
a serenidade beleza e assim valor
as criaturas da guerra com as suas
flechas pretas e o seu desejo de
destruição também usa o otimismo a
competência a persistência coragem a
criatividade até mesmo a humildade
um ladrão um impostor um bandido todos
eles também podem usar essas habilidades
está a diferença
a diferença desse jovem está nos valores
de cada um
sim mas porque seus valores perguntou
anima os valores estão contidos nos
princípios éticos e morais de cada
pessoa disse ele
sim mas não dessa que tudo espontâneo
natural e universal ele perguntou então
finalmente o jovem percebeu estava
falando amor o amor disse anima ser a
única moeda aceita em todas as épocas
em todos os lugares por onde vai passar
o meu próximo e dos seus efeitos não
seja intolerante
todos os viajantes que encontrar pelo
caminho então como você e cada um à sua
maneira em busca da mesma base espírita
enquanto o homem tiver amigos gente que
ele ama e que eu amo ele será feliz mas
se não tiver esse laço de amor com a
vida não terá razão para continuar
vivendo
lembre se ver é infinita
você é que irá determinar com as suas
atitudes
é como gerar sua viagem vou mostrar sua
vida e como serão as suas realizações
despediram se com um abraço um abraço de
alma
o ruído dos passos europa das plantas
indicavam que logo seria hora de partir
foram meus alunos hoje foi muito esforço
pra vocês muito obrigado obrigado